bonjour sahelaillerie bonjour hier soir
l'Assemblée nationale a rejeté l'article
2 de la réforme des retraites celui sur
l'index senior c'est quand même un sacré
revers pour le gouvernement puis c'est
pas de bonne augure pour la suite
surtout vous savez il y a effectivement
les grands perdants ce sont les seniors
puisque l'article 2 a été rejeté et donc
nous ne pourrons pas avoir
d'informations complémentaires et en
réalité la transparence sur l'emploi des
seniors le nerfs
c'est index senior qui était pas non
plus
un dispositif très contraignant ce n'est
pas l'alpha Omega ça ne résout pas tout
ça c'est certain par contre ce qui était
utile avec cette annexe des seniors et
c'est pour ça que nous l'avions proposé
c'est de permettre et bien de mettre en
lumière des entreprises qui licencient
des seniors simplement parce que ils
sont ils arrivent à la veille des trois
ans avant le départ en retraite parce
que aujourd'hui il se pose la question
de finalement il va finir sa carrière sa
carrière au chômage c'est honteux ce
n'est pas satisfaisant et donc notre vol
c'était de mettre en lumière dans toutes
les entreprises cette information pour
aussi peut-être travailler sur peut-être
des sanctions peut-être des bonus malus
peut-être d'autres éléments mais en tout
cas permettre à toutes les personnes qui
arrivent en fin de carrière et bien
d'avoir un taux d'emploi plus élevé vous
vous avez vos alliés dans cette réforme
c'est la droite elle est pas fiable en
l'occurrence elle a voté compte enfin
une bonne partie des députés ont voté
contre vous savez ce que dans le fond ce
que je salue malgré cette perte de
l'index des seniors les débats
continueront c'est peut-être sortir de
l'outrans des injures parce que dans le
fond qu'est-ce qui est le plus important
dans cette réforme et bien qu'elle soit
débattue et que finalement chacun assume
ses positions et assume et bien ses
propositions aussi ce qu'on voit hier
c'est que effectivement un article a été
battu nous en prenons acte les débats
continueront j'espère simplement qu'il
se continueront dans le calme et la
sérénité est-ce que vous pensez que ce
rejet de l'article 2 il peut donner des
ailes à la gauche et notamment vous
pensez que d'ici vendredi minuit et bien
la gauche les insoumis notamment
retireront leurs amendements pour
pouvoir aller sur l'article 7 qui est le
recul d'âge vous savez c'est ni une
victoire du gouvernement ni de la
majorité ni des oppositions la grande
victorieuse si nous arrivons à aller
jusqu'au bout du débat et bien c'est
simplement la démocratie elle-même et
les Français eux-mêmes aujourd'hui les
Français ils demandent quoi de la
transparence une qualité de débat pour
savoir quels sont les positions des uns
et des autres donc s'il y avait une
volonté mais parce que je suis une
parlementaire élu est réélu sur ma
circonscription c'est que je souhaite
que oui et bien les amendements les plus
superflus soit retirés pour permettre le
reste encore
14000 14000 encore ce qui ne permet pas
physiquement et techniquement d'aller au
bout cependant il y a un mouvement qui
est fait aujourd'hui de retrait espérons
que l'outrans les injures disparaissent
et que les fins la fin des débats se
passent dans de bonnes qualités parce
que nous devons la transparence en
français un petit mot rapide juste sur
ce fameux 47 1 à 47 ans c'est une
procédure qui qui contraint le débat
dans un dans un temps précis 50 jours en
tout c'était une bonne idée de faire ça
écoutez je pense que le temps était
permis le temps était long s'il n'avait
pas eu autant de suspension de séance
autant de troubles dans la forme si on
n'avait pas eu autant d'outrage
d'injures le débat aurait peut-être de
qualité et puis revenons à l'essentiel
c'est une du prix de la France insoumise
qui a fait que il y a autant
d'amendements et donc une volonté
d'obstruction mais une volonté politique
d'obstruction donc c'est plutôt assumé
peut-être un dernier mot avant de sur ce
sujet il ne faut pas retourner la charge
la réforme des retraites elle est
nécessaire parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin de protéger ce système par
répartition et donc de permettre au plus
jeune demain d'avoir une retraite et je
crois que c'est le mot essentiel de
cette réforme une précision encore sur
la pension minimum à 1200 euros on
n'arrive pas bien à comprendre combien
de retraités précisément sont concernés
par cette mesure vous savez je ne suis
pas la ministre en charge de la réforme
des retraites moi je suis en charge de
la jeunesse par contre ce que je peux
vous dire sur les 1200 euros nous avons
besoin de protéger les carrières les
plus hachées
principalement d'ailleurs des femmes qui
se retrouvent avec les pensions les plus
faibles à la fin et donc pour ne plus
avoir de pension extrêmement faible
cette augmentation à 1200 permettra une
une revalorisation de la pension au delà
la même chose de dire que
près de 1 million 8 traités seront
touchés ou beaucoup moins on a
l'impression que
vous avez peut-être un peu
dissimuler la vérité soit notamment sur
l'ampleur et l'impact pas du tout de
Saillon très clair composition des 1200
euros permettra aux personnes qui ont
leur cotisations pleine et une pension
en deçà d'avoir une augmentation réelle
et donc d'arriver au milieu
à temps complet avec toutes ces
retraites et un salaire équivalent au
SMIC ça veut dire que ça concerne très
peu de personnes ça concernement des
économies
de femmes qui ont vu parce qu'ils ont eu
des emplois plus hachés ou des emplois
de moins bien payés finalement des
pensions extrêmement basse et vous savez
le fait que ça touche aujourd'hui les
retraités qu'ils sont déjà et demain
celles ou ceux qui arriveront à la
retraite est un avancée est un droit et
donc dans le fond ça améliore notre
système ça n'améliore pas tout bien sûr
la question essentielle ça reste comment
on équilibre donc c'est pas chiffré pour
l'instant on ne sait pas combien de
retraités évidemment que ces chiffres et
ces chiffres et ses portés par le
ministre du travail lui-même il se
trouve que je suis en charge de la
jeunesse de son élan et donc d'abord la
question démographique
cette jeunesse Emmanuel Macron il devait
faire des annonces sur la généralisation
du service national universel ça devait
être en novembre ensuite ça devait être
en janvier ce sera peut-être finalement
fin mars pourquoi est-ce qu'il retarde
sans cesse les annonces sur ce sujet le
projet n'est pas retardé il se trouve
que amanomination la mission qui m'a été
donnée c'est d'apporter la
généralisation du projet pourquoi le
service national universel est une
chance nous avons besoin de cohésion
nationale nous avons besoin que nos
jeunes et bien gouttent au goût de la
rencontre de l'effort de la mobilité
quelle que soit leur classe sociale quel
que soit leur territoire et je suis en
train de mener les méditation nécessaire
on comprend fignoler peaufiner ce on
comprend l'intérêt de votre point de vue
mais qu'est-ce qui coince il a c'était
une promesse de 2017 il a renouvelé
cette promesse à ses vœux du 31 décembre
ça fait beaucoup rien ne coin puisque
aujourd'hui nous continuons à recevoir
des jeunes en service national universel
d'ailleurs dès le 19 février un certain
nombre de jeunes iront en Île-de-France
et en Occitanie pour vivre cette
aventure les annonces qui arriveront
donc
les annonces arriveront quel que soit le
calendrier vous avez aujourd'hui j'ai
besoin de réunir l'ensemble des parties
prenantes les associations de parents
les associations de l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui les élus locaux
les collectivités mais aussi les cultes
les associations d'éducation populaire
c'est un projet pour la France et donc
le peaufiner le fignolet c'est une
chance parce que pour une fois vous
savez nous avons pas un texte et nous
faisons un acte de conviction pour
l'expliquer ou le vendre on le construit
avec les parties prenantes et donc je
pense que c'est une chance d'avoir ce
temps complémentaire vous dites le
fignoler ça veut dire que vous devez
quand même déjà savoir si ce sera une
extension du s&u ou une obligation deux
hypothèses sont aujourd'hui sur la table
et présentés au
présentes sont présentées et dans les
deux nous avons poussé l'expertise et
donc nous consultons j'ai fait plus de
40 consultations ces dernières semaines
donc vous vous ne savez toujours pas si
ce serait une extension ou une
obligation on a toujours une préférence
plus personnelle parce que la vôtre moi
je crois que plus il touchera de jeunes
plus il permettra la mixité plus il sera
aussi sur le temps scolaire puisque
c'est une des hypothèses où l'autre sur
les vacances plus il sera finalement
accessible à tous parce que je vois
aujourd'hui c'est que ce sont les jeunes
dans les familles on le capital social
le plus élevé qui envoie leurs enfants
en service national en 10 secondes
est-ce que il y a pas aussi derrière ça
ce recul ou en tout cas cette attente
une peur finalement que les de mobiliser
les jeunes contre le projet des
retraites vous voyez qui est tout d'un
coup vous voulez dire en réalité le
service national universel c'est un
nouveau droit vous allez permettre à
l'ensemble des jeunes de vivre une
mobilité totalement prise en charge par
l'État parce qu'il n'y a pas de
gratitude qui existe mais prise en
charge en égalité universalité jeune
fille jeune garçon bon pour les Provins
préparer au défi de notre temps c'est
une chance on va être patiente
d'ailleurs du coup j'habite ce que ça
intéresse à découvrir le dispositif et à
s'inscrire merci beaucoup sert à Hélène
et bonne journée bien sûr merci beaucoup
on se retrouve pour parler notamment de
la réforme des